voler comme un super héros
ce n'est plus un rêve c'est une réalité
un seul oiseau elle sonne avion mais non
c'est jeff mann l'entreprise et son
homme volant viennent d'accomplir une
nouvel exploit décoller en partant du
sol plutôt que d'une plateforme élevé ou
d'un hélicoptère le costume munie de
quatre mini moteurs à réaction et des
lentilles de carbone est entièrement
contrôlée par humains et permet
d'atteindre une vitesse de 400
kilomètres à l'heure
lors de ce vol à dubaï nomme oiseaux a
survolé le golfe persique à 1800 mètres
d'altitude
une véritable prouesse d'ingénierie
prochaine étape pour jetman réussir un
atterrissage tout en douceur sans
parachute
[Musique]